>>> HEY, GUYS.
I'M CHLOE FINEMAN.
IT'S BEEN A REALLY UNIQUE
SEASON.
AND PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS ASKING
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A CAST MEMBER
HAS TO MISS A SHOW BECAUSE
THEY'RE SICK?
WELL, THAT'S WHERE I COME IN.
I AM THE SHOW'S OFFICIAL
UNDERSTUDY.
SO EVERY WEEK, I RUN LINES WITH
ALL THE CAST MEMBERS JUST IN
CASE I NEED TO JUMP INTO THEIR
ROLE.
>> DO YOU THINK WE CAN TAKE IT
FROM THE TOP OF THE SKETCH?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
MET GALA, KATE IS AN "E! NEWS"
CORRESPONDENT.
>> OKAY.
SO -- HEY, GUYS, HOW ARE YOU?
>> WHAT?
WHAT?
GOD, WHAT?
>> YOU WANT TO GET MORE INTIMATE
WITH IT.
YOU WANT TO DO A BIGGER SPREAD.
SPREAD AS BIG AS YOU CAN.
JUST MAKE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THEN YOU'VE GOT TO REALLY GET IN
AND GET INTIMATE.
>> HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> TO REALLY CAPTURE THE ESSENCE
OF A CAST MEMBER, YOU HAVE TO
SHADOW THEM AS THEY GO ABOUT
THEIR EVERYDAY ROUTINES.
>> YEAH, WELL, I THOUGHT IT WAS
FUNNY, BUT DURING THE SHOW IT
WASN'T ON THE CUE CARD.
>> IT WASN'T ON THE CUE CARD,
NO, NO.
>> HUH, WOW.
>> WELL.
>> WELL, YEAH.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S PRETTY GOOD, I GOT A
MASSAGE.
>> SOME OF THE CAST MEMBERS USE
ME AS AN UNDERSTUDY FOR THEIR
PERSONAL LIVES.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR DOING
THIS, CHLOE.
I'M SO BAD AT BREAKUPS.
>> TRULY, NO PROBLEM.
>> HEY, CHLOE.
OH, NO.
BUT I SEE IT AS MORE OF A POEM,
YOU KNOW?
SO, IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO WORK
OUT.
>> THANKS PAL, YOU'RE THE BEST.
>> OH, MAN.
I FRICKIN' LOVE YOU.
>> UNDERSTUDIES HAVE A VERY
STRICT CODE OF ETHICS.
LIKE, NO MATTER HOW GOOD MY
ELIZABETH OLSEN IMPRESSION IS, I
WOULD NEVER USE TO IT TRICK
BENEDICT.
>> BENEDICT, IT'S YOUR FRIEND
ELIZABETH OLSEN.
>> HEY, YOU MADE IT.
YOU'RE IN COSTUME.
>> I LOVE MARVEL.
HA HA HA!
AND SPEAKING OF, DO YOU KNOW WHO
WOULD BE GREAT IN THE NEXT
DOCTOR STRANGE IS "SNL'S"
UNDERSTUDY CHLOE FINEMAN.
>> BENEDICT, WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THOUGHT I WAS TALKING TO
YOU.
>> NO, I'M ME.
>> NO, SO AM I.
>> I AM ME.
>> I AM ME TOO.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THE MULTIVERSE IS REAL.
OH.
>> HAS ANYONE ASKED ME TO BE AN
UNDERSTUDY?
NO.
BUT THEY HAVEN'T ASKED ME TO
STOP.
>> OKAY, GUYS.
RAPID FIRE.
TELL ME IF I GET IT.
AIDY?
GOOGLY, GABBLELY.
>> NAILED IT, BAD-ASS.
>> HEIDI.
>> HEY, DUDE.
>> WE'RE STRONG SO FAR.
>> SARAH.
>> HELLO, HELLO!
>> WAIT, DO I SOUND LIKE A
JEWISH PARROT?
>> OKAY, WHO'S LEFT?
>> PASS.
>> AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> I KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
THINKING.
WHAT HAPPENS IF I GET SICK?
WELL I ACTUALLY HAVE MY OWN
UNDERSTUDY WHO DOES A PERFECT
IMPRESSION OF ME.
>> YO --!